what did you wait my fridge yeah you got
something you want to tell us Todd how
far along is the pregnancy ha ha ha no
I'm stress-eating right now just
downloaded a new dating app and I have
like zero messages let me see a profile
picture I look great yeah that's weird
why'd you retouch your abs did Yuri edit
one nipple higher than the other
well abs yes but I didn't touch the
nipples right in plus you guys don't
know anything about relationships oh
okay I'm married okay
okay here's what you need to do you just
got to change that picture yeah what you
need a picture with people in it show
that you're fun and normal what about
Halloween huh yeah we had some cool
pictures from that that's an oldie but a
goodie classic wait wait should we wait
for Todd right now we just look like a
sad salad
hey we got a boo I think I hit like a
parked car or something oh but Todd
where's your burger patty costume what's
with the boat uh-huh right we give to
all women Todd I'm the receipt no I
didn't dude you ruin the whole burger
costume come on it's gonna be great it's
gonna be great free drinks all night
because I'm gonna be getting free drinks
shut up no one Todd here we go I'm gonna
go blow I'm gonna go fine go low mmm
okay okay they say that you should use a
profile pic that children in Houston I
can do my fantasy-football drop from the
commissioner
what is that shows a lot of leadership
you you kind of like to hike remember
remember the hiking trip yeah okay guys
ready uh-huh
oh oh oh my god
keeps asking if I got cold um no you're
separate in the male form that's a
direct Peck pick okay okay hold on I got
this Vegas okay I might be the only one
who remembers it but you looked great
that night Wow milah take another one
taking the one look I'm sorry I think
there's a misunderstanding yeah we asked
you to take a picture of us not be in
the phonetic semantics I can't find any
pictures where you're not hanging out
with club girls so what that's a giant
red flag okay no one wants to date a guy
that hangs out with other hot chicks I
got it
use this one Oh me and your grandma's
cat yes you're relaxed you're smiling
with teeth there's a cat with a cap my
heart is melting okay I'll do that
but um Traci's my real name yes
absolutely
what did you write I wanted to get
Little Dipper but it was taken because I
like to be the little spoon that's awful
that's terrible you guys want to do this
I know thank you
yeah no I'm gonna eat all of it